- All right y'all,
(audience applauds)
it's almost time to say goodbye,
but do not worry, we have
one more story to share.
This is, "#What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
So I love getting to know the music scene
here in New York.
This city has always been a magnet
for up-and-coming performers.
An artist collective
known as Keepsake House
continues that tradition.
Each live show mixes
songwriting with storytelling,
creating a Keepsake experience
for the audience, super cool.
Let's get the founders in here.
Everybody say hello to Hailey and Jasmine.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- What's up y'all?
- Hi, Kelly.
- So Hailey, I'm gonna start with you.
You came up with the idea, right?
- Yeah, both of us did.
So I'm an event planner
and Jasmine's a musician from New York
and we sort of saw this need
to have a more community space
for independent artists here,
especially BIPOC and LGBTQ plus artists
because it's so competitive in the city.
So we started Keepsake House,
which is a home for independent
artists to share the stage
and make music with meaning.
All of our shows bring together
songwriters and storytellers.
They share the stage and
learn from each other
and they also benefit other
like-minded organizations.
So we've actually raised over $7,000
for Asian Pacific American
mental health focused organizations.
- Wow, that's so cool.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, and yeah,
ultimately we just wanna
be a home that feels safe
and supportive for
anyone who comes into it,
whether a performer or an audience.
- Absolutely, this is, look,
I lived in Nashville for
like nearly 15 years.
This reminds me of like
walking into like Bluebird
or a place like that,
like they have them everywhere there
and you see these stories,
these songs being told,
these artists with the songwriters.
It's a very cool experience.
Did y'all kind of take a
page from that, Jasmine?
- Yeah, Hailey and I both
have visited Nashville
and love that that city,
and one of the things
we love most about it
is the round table style
shows that they have there
with multiple artists on stage,
taking turns playing their songs.
We love sort of the openness
and collaboration behind that
and wanted to bring that to New York.
And actually Kelly, we
livestream all of our shows
and we have one coming
up on Friday this week.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- At pinkFROG in Williamsburg, New York,
but you can watch it anywhere.
So if you are around,
we'd love to see you.
- Oh, that's incredible.
And I can, I just say it's so cool too,
like you're seeing something different
every time y'all do these shows.
Like these are different
songwriters, different stories,
different just moments.
I think that's so special, you know?
Like you're not seeing the
same thing all the time.
Like you know, sometimes when
you go on tour to see artists
that's what you get, you know?
And I think it's really cool
that you're like specializing
it for the audience.
It's very cool.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- We always say you'll never
see another show like it,
'cause there you won't
see that set of artists
on stage together.
- Which is cool.
Like in a time where
everything is always online
right after it's done,
it's hard to create
that kind of experience.
So well done and such
a good cause as well.
Thank you so much
Jasmine. Thank you Hailey.
(audience applauding)
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all, our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the Go-To Erasable Pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
wanna celebrate creators
just like yourselves,
so they're giving you a thousand dollars,
that's $500 each
(audience applauding)
just to help out in whatever way it can.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Brie Larson, Brandy Clark,
Alan Stewart, David Ehrenberg,
Cash Warren, and Daniel Parnas.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.